when you start thinking about Alexa and
all these other things one of the things
that my career has been completely
predicated on is the fact that I am
willing to take chances on things that
aren't mainstream yet because I
understand that if I go after social
code and if I go after vine and if I go
after Mi'kmaq and if I go after yak and
if I go after all these things that I
only need one of those seven to actually
hit snapchat Instagram to win that bet
we have enormous fear in this room - I
have to wait or let's wait - it's big or
what if I waste my time awkward right
yeah super awkward you could leave if
you want but you can show - got it
well I waste my time on these platforms
right well I waste my time on these
platforms if it doesn't become big and
so one of the other themes that I really
wanted to leave here with tonight
knowing the demo of this room is we have
to have a lot more risk tolerance on new
platforms if you're not playing back to
details and I know you're taking notes
if you're not playing with Marco Polo
and after school and house party then
you're not there potentially at the
platforms that can become the next
things at the top of our tongue how many
people here let's be really honest let's
be really really really honest with
ourselves inbound please raise your hand
if this is true how many people in this
room and I want everybody look around
said two and a half years ago three
years ago maybe even a year ago that
they would never be on snapchat that was
stupid and now have a snapchat account
raise your hands raise it high higher
this this is where all the action is
this is where all the action is this is
the opportunity in this room but we
continue to downplay we continue to
downplay the upside cuz we fear the risk
of being on there and wasting time if
you have not achieved what you want to
professionally or in life time is the
number one thing you've got you need to
deploy as much of that as humanly
possible that is the asset when you have
not achieved the things that you want to
happen in life and it is because of time
that you ever wanted to put into these
platforms of Worlds that is a massive
mistake it's the one asset
you have not everybody in this room has
money it's true you agree right so are
you gonna work your [ __ ] face off
thank you it's the one thing we have
it's the one thing we have because
everybody wants to come up with excuses
I spend my life reading excuses on
social media and my inbox um this I
wasn't born that way
I wasn't born here this a female I'm an
immigrant I'm a minority I'm a
transgender excuses reality by the way I
truly believe those are disadvantages
I'm not naive to the shortcomings of
this country the problem is nobody cares
the market doesn't care so we sit and we
dwell and it's so what do you think
we've been doing for the last month and
what we're gonna do tomorrow morning
we're gonna dwell and complain and
that's utter defense instead of going on
the offense and so we spend unbelievable
amounts of time dwelling and wasting our
time on dumb [ __ ] like people literally
email me and say you're so lucky and I
wish this was happening to me and then
the third tweet or the third Instagram
post is awesome Saturday stayed home and
watch the entire season a [ __ ] Game
of Thrones
we need to start understanding how big
this opportunity is because for
everybody in this room you will sit back
in 20 30 years and regret if you didn't
execute in this era and by the way I
don't want to hear that this is for 20
and 30 year olds 40 50 60 70 it's an
equal playing field if you're willing to
be a practitioner and understand the
ecosystem that I've been speaking about
tonight there's never been a better time
look it's very honest these kind of
characters there was no respect for 20
year olds in the business world 20 years
ago when I came out but now because of
Technology there's a lot of
organizations that absolutely respect 20
and 30 year olds also what is happening
is I'm spending so much time with 40 to
60 year old executives who are dwelling
and are upset and tell me dumb [ __ ] like
but Gary I didn't grow up with this [ __ ]
neither did I Alice
I was 20 before I even was on a computer
I didn't grow up with this [ __ ] I
figured it out and so I sit there and
see completely capable operators that
have made it happen for the last twenty
thirty years being crippled by I don't
understand how snapchat works it's so
confusing
we're just filled with excuses we are
people are just losing their hunger and
then and then by the way let me get
really mad for two seconds with my fancy
rich friends
the thing that I'm completely blown away
by that I had no idea what's going on in
capitalism and meritocracy is once you
get rich you actually try to spend your
dollars to create laws that allow you
not to work and still hold on to your
money a hundred percent right I mean I'm
blown away by this you were benefit you
were benefited because in your 20s to
sixty for 40 years you grinded and out
executed somebody and you were able to
make lots of money but now that you're
tired and you're finished and you're
older and don't want to put in the work
you don't want the next young buck to
come along and eat your lunch
that's not how capitalism works it's
true it's just not and so we have all
these trends and we have the great
fortune of living in an era where things
have been really good for a very long
time and so I walk around the world and
I told my wife Lizzie I'm like Lizzie
listen to me I don't care clearly
because I was such a [ __ ] student what
the kids do at school but please they
can't be in programs where we give away
seventh place trophies I have no idea
who wins the election tonight but we
need to [ __ ] ban seventh place
trophies in America and so we have all
these macro situations going on and not
to mention for a lot of people here
under 30 you haven't been in the game
during an economic downturn cuz things
have been very cushy for the last seven
years where if you're 23 years old and
you have an idea your companies
miraculously worth four million dollars
and so we're living in a very intriguing
time and I think that the passion and
the angst and the energy that I bring
tonight are predicated on a couple
tried-and-true things number one if
you're not making long-term decisions
you will be vulnerable the markets
changing very quickly and anybody who's
looking for short-term stuff gets
short-term stuff and then gets hurt in
the long term things like Airbnb guys
Airbnb shouldn't have been invented by
Brian and Joe Airbnb should have been
invented by Marriott but Marriott is
looking short-term and isn't creating
business models to put themselves out of
business
uber should have not been created by
garret and right they shouldn't they
should have not been created by Garrett
and Travis they should have been created
by the guy or girl that owned the most
medallions in New York City or by
Greyhound if you sit here tonight and
you're doing well
you're in danger because there's
somebody young and hungry that has the
internet which is a platform that
creates a zero cost to get into the game
that's coming after your [ __ ] so if you
don't do what I do which is wake up
every single morning every single
morning and try to put yourself out of
business somebody else is gonna do it
for you it is much more fun my friends
to put yourself out of business
than have somebody else do it for you
and so please if your cushy whose cushy
raise your hand if shit's going real
well Jesus Christ
three people raise their hand I think
you need to shut down this [ __ ]
you're doing good
awesome what was that I was like you're
doing good yeah we're doing okay yeah
yeah always
so you've got to understand the only
thing that's interesting to me and the
only thing I have I always say that
basically my career is predicated much
more similar to Mariano Rivera than
anything else that I can think of if
you're a baseball fan he was a very good
closure for the New York Yankees where
basically his entire career was
predicated on one pitch he had one pitch
for 17 years and nobody could hit it and
that's basically my business career I've
got one pitch which is the following
I know what you're gonna do before you
know you're gonna do it it's the thing
that I was gifted with just like if you
can sing just like it shoot I've always
had the intuition I was made fun of and
aggressively made fun of for launching a
website in 1996 because just like people
sit here and think that vine or snapchat
is a fad there's people in this room
that remember where the whole internet
was a fad but I bet on it and I built a
big business and then I was made fun of
because this thing called YouTube came
out and I took a chance on that because
I thought it was gonna be big and
started a wine show and sat in front of
a camera and drank four bottles of wine
for 20 minutes and hundreds of thousands
of people watched it and then that
worked and then Twitter worked and I
invested in Twitter and Facebook and
things of that nature but I had so many
losses along the way one thing that's
never talked about with my genius career
was that I was on YouTube super early
but I left six months in and started
producing Wine Library TV exclusively on
viddler I was wrong one thing that's not
talked about is that I thought that the
biggest startup in the world in 2010 was
gonna be yo Bongo I was wrong and I
continued to be interested in being
wrong for the rest of my life because I
am a purebred entrepreneur because I'm
not scared of trying things and wasting
my valuable time because I want things
and most of all and this is the most of
all the whole thing I just genuinely
don't give a [ __ ] about what you think
about me
[Applause]
balanced with I really care about what
everybody says about me and in that
friction I mean that you have to deploy
real ego and real humility around this
course because we live in that world but
if I could inspire anything in the time
that I was here today it's very simply
this please do me one favor I'm gonna
wrap it up with this and this matters so
much to me please whatever it takes call
your grandmother go to your great
grandfather's burial spot go back to the
old country go to a shelter do something
do something that recalibrates
your perspective on what is actually
going on here we have never had it
better
my friends I'm gonna leave you with a
very interesting data point you guys
like data
who likes data great let me give you
some [ __ ] data more people in America
will die from a coconut falling out of a
tree and hitting you on the head and
killing you than terrorism yeah I see
you tentative like is he [ __ ] serious
I'm dead [ __ ] serious kids 7:00 to
11:00 watched more twitch eSports then
all the four major sports combined
that's data we were living through a
totally different time ten years ago the
weirdest thing in the world was your
friend dated people online now every
single person swipes to the left and
right 24/7 and so the trends and our
society have changed and either you're
gonna sit here and binary this is a
black and white conversation either
you're gonna leave here and understand
how [ __ ] awesome it is and you're
gonna take full advantage of it and be a
winner
or you're gonna sit and dwell on all the
negatives of it and be a losing player
it's just the truth it's not complicated
it's not fun for me to say I don't want
you to lose I desperately want you to
win but this is on you nobody else is in
control there are people who deal with
like the loss of their children or real
diseases were sitting and dwelling about
not getting enough likes on [ __ ]
Instagram we're sitting and dwelling
about forces that don't really have
impact on us it is time that this
collective room and our space
understands this is the greatest golden
era of not only business but life and
you're really and I mean really need to
[ __ ] grab it thank you
[Applause]
you